so there's multiple people shot okay
tragedies like the mass shooting in
Tucson are horrifying enough on their
own but they also have a way of bringing
out the worst and reporters and
politicians in fact knee-jerk reactions
often leave us with misconceptions and
bad policies that stick around long
after the healing has begun and that's
why reason TV presents five rules for
coping with tragedy
remember the Columbine school shooting
contrary to first impressions the two
murders weren't Goths Nazis loners or
whacked-out video gamers and they didn't
target jocks blacks or Christians they
weren't bullied into their killing spree
either in fact they bragged about
picking on freshmen and gays as accused
gunman Jared Lofton is eclectic list of
favorite books including mine column
from the Communist Manifesto and The
Wizard of Oz suggests killers rarely
fall neatly into simplistic left/right
categories and even when they do you
can't discredit an entire movement based
on the actions of random outliers an
anti-abortion murderer like Scott Roeder
doesn't debunk pro-life views any more
than an environmentalist hostage taker
like James J Lee discredits belief in
renewable energy sources reporters and
politicians constantly assert that
today's rhetoric is more heated than
ever but political rhetoric is almost
always at a boiling point as the makers
of the 2006 film the death of a
president which imagined the
assassination of George W Bush could
tell you so could 19th century
politicians who actually beat each other
on the Senate floor
mass killings are horrific but they're
also rare you're much more likely to be
killed by something like a car accident
and we should try to fear things in
proportion to the actual threat they
pose but a frenzied media and
opportunistic polls often create the
impression of an epidemic even when the
evidence suggests otherwise
the Columbine massacre set off countless
news reports about school shootings even
as schools were getting safer it never
makes sense to create policy in the heat
of the moment that goes for massive
financial bailouts like tarp and it goes
from measures like the Patriot Act which
was signed into law just days after the
9/11 attacks and wasn't even read by the
members of Congress who said its passage
was essential to protecting the United
States now we're stuck with the TSA
security theater
thanks to politicians knee-jerk
real-time reactions that typically get
set and legislative concrete tragedies
are terrible all by themselves
we survivors shouldn't make things worse